hi everyone I'm Stephen King the author
of the epic Dark Tower saga and just
like you I've waited a long time for
Roman Dan the man in black to hit the
big screen but the time is finally here
so don't wait any longer get your
tickets and seed The Dark Tower spoiler
alert you're gonna love it
The Dark Tower has always been really
important to me it's been the one story
that never really leaves me alone I just
keep coming back to it
Stephen King's cop tower takes you right
into a place that you can't even imagine
the dark towers really corridor that
connects all of Stephen King's er misery
the stand and it the shining this is his
magnum opus the tower will fall roland
deschain he's guns and a protector of
the tower from the man in black
it's the age-old tale good versus evil
I've been fighting the man in black for
centuries
he's like the devil isn't he no he's
worse fine line I'm walking because he's
the only one that could deliver me yet
I'm the only one that can deliver him
you can't stop what's coming death
always
I will kill him for both of us
whoever you've read the books or not you
got into Johnny I'm enjoying this game
you see these characters come to life in
films it's really incredible
can I shoot with my head
I shoot of my mind I did not kill with
my gun I killed my heart how is all that
stands between light and darkness
thousands of generations the gunslingers
with Knights sworn detective I'm the
only one left the tower will fall
Houston carnage
now the wors comes earth
you really think you can stop me gun
singer
everyone who walks with you dies no more
can I shoot with my hand
I shoot with my mind
yo of my god
I killed my heart
you